v d'être allégé à partir du 15 novembre
prochain le pass sanitaire pourrait
finalement être prolongée jusqu'à fin
juillet 2022 prolongation prévue par
l'article 2 du projet de loi vigilance
sanitaire examiné aujourd'hui par les
députés plus de 380 amendements ont été
déposés pour la première lecture de ce
texte une majorité concerne cette
prolongation ou trop versé ou en parler
on retrouve en direct notre reportage
sur place le cas légers
pour soir lucas une manifestation est
organisée à l'extérieur quelle est
l'ambiance ici
[Musique]
et bien des manifestants qui sont venus
à plusieurs centaines ici devant
l'assemblée nationale à l'appel
notamment du parti les patriotes 2
florian philippot je vous propose de
regarder sur ces images de julien
guitare qui m'accompagne l'ambiance ces
manifestants sont massés devant une
tribune où le président des patriotes a
pris la parole il ya quelques minutes et
il a dit que les français ne
conditionnait pas leur liberté à un qr
code ici les mots d'ordre restent les
mêmes depuis le départ réouverture du
pays et le slogan liberté derrière les
murs de l'assemblée nationale commence
le débat sur la loi qui va définir le
la prolongation des mesures sanitaires
après le 15 novembre pour l'instant il
est prévu notamment de
des sanctions sévères pour les personnes
qui frauderait se passe sanitaires ça a
été critiquée par le président des
patriotes je vous propose d'écouter
quelques manifestants avec qui j'ai pu
parler au cours de ce rassemblement qui
touche à sa fin maintenant
je trouve ça inacceptable c'est un
manque de liberté c'est une f c'est une
atteinte à la liberté à la démocratie
c'est une histoire politique qui n'est
même plus une histoire de santé oms n'a
pas faire pression comme ça sur les gens
en leur imposant un passant les menaçant
de de suspension en les menaçant de
licenciement
chacun doit être libre de se faire
vacciner ou pas et je trouve ça
scandaleux la manière dont le
gouvernement le président se comporte
avec nous il ya de moins en moins deux
morts quand on compare le taux de co
vide à des gens qui meurent chaque jour
du cancer ou d'autres maladies
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment n'importe
quoi c'est juste pour nous priver de
liberté de plus en plus il n'y a plus
aucune crédibilité ce gouvernement c'est
tout ce que je peux vous dire vous
n'avez plus aucune crédibilité
c'est toi un peu de chances de se voir
en travers à l'assemblée nationale ça
pourrait être plus difficile devant le
sénat le président de la chambre haute a
dit qu'il ne donnerait pas un
blanc-seing au gouvernement pour agir
sans le contrôle du parlement et bien
sûr il y aura toujours une mobilisation
dans la rue ces manifestants sont
toujours déterminés comme depuis des
mois ils réclament la réouverture totale
du pays merci beaucoup le cas légers en
direct donc de cette manifestation des
patriotes devant l'assemblée nationale
merci à vous